تداعي البنوك الصغرى في الولايات المتحده
يبث الرعب في القطاع البنكي ويعيد الى
الواجهه شبح الازمه الماليه العالميه لسنه
2008 ولحد الان تقتصر الازمه على البنوك
الصغرى في البنوك الكبرى لا تزال في مامن
بسبب توافر السيوله لديها لكن هذا لم يمنع
من اثاره بعض المخاوف من احتمال حدوث ازمه
ماليه عالميه كسابقتها في 2008 السؤال
الذي يطفو على السطح الان هو الفرق بين
الازمه الحاليه والازمه الماليه العالميه
السابقه في العموم مشاهدينا هناك بعض
الاختلافات التي تجعل الازمه الماليه
الحاليه مختلفه عن ازمه سنه 2008 فخلال
الازمه الماليه العالميه الماليه الماضيه
اذن تضررت كل البنوك المؤسسات الماليه
كبيره وصغيره اما هذه المره فالمتضرره
بشده هي البنوك الصغيره والمتوسطه كما ان
الاصلاحات التي اعقبت ازمه 2008 ادت الى
وضع قواعد لحفظ سلامه القطاع المصرفي
وهو ما استفدت منه الكثير من البنوك في
الازمه الحاليه ومن اوجه الاختلافات ايضا
التدخل السريع للدوله في الازمه الحاليه
عكس سنه 2008 حين تدخلت بعد فوات الاوامر
كما ان الوضع الاقتصادي يختلف بين
الفترتين فالنمو الاقتصادي متزايد في
الوقت الراهن بينما ارتسمت الفتره التي
سبقت ازمه 2008 بركود كبير